وبشان خطط الجيش الاسرائيلي خلال الفتره
المقبله نفى المتحدث باسمه دانييل ها جاري
وجود اي نيه لدي لدى الجيش للانسحاب من
خانيونس او اي مكان اخر في قطاع غزه مؤكدا
ان الحرب تستغرق وقتا وانه يتم تكييفها مع
الاخطار في الميدان ووضع الاسرى اضاف ه
جاري ان الجيش يواصل التعاون مع جهاز
الامن العام الشباك للقضاء على قاده حماس
لا ننوي التراجع في خان يونس او اي مكان
اخر العمليه العسكريه تستغرق وقتا وتتطلب
منا ان نكون دقيقين ونئ امها بما يتناسب
مع الاخطار ووضع الاسرى في المنطقه لا
توجد طريقه اسرع يستغرق الامر وقتا وقبل
كل شيء يتطلب المرونه ونحن نعمل بالتعاون
مع الشباك للقضاء على قاده حماس كل يوم
نقيم اعم لنا وسع جاهد للفوق
اكر